on en aurait observé un de cette semaine
être en australie le grand requin blanc
continue à réveiller tous les fantasmes
tellement le mystère autour ce géant des
mers
le requin blanc l'un des plus grands
poissons prédateurs des océans possède
désormais son sosie reconstitué au
muséum d'histoire naturelle exposée pour
la première fois lors de la nuit des
musées 2016 cette maquette grandeur
nature a nécessité plusieurs mois de
travail c'était une commande de madame
bribes pour l'exposition requin depuis
deux ans suite à une capture
accidentelle de requins donc j'ai réussi
à voir les mensurations du requin par
l'université ont par la suite j'ai fait
une maquette à l'échelle 1 7e en pâte à
modeler qui était validée par exotiques
de l'université plusieurs étapes ont été
nécessaires pour reproduire à
l'identique ce requin blanc péché par
erreur à quelques encablures de nos
côtes
pour pouvoir se rendre compte des
véritables dimensions du spécimen chaque
détail de la reconstitution est
essentiel que l'illusion soit parfaite
j'ai refait le requin en l'échelle 1
donc c'est cet effet en polystyrène et
de sujet remis pour cette éthique pour
pouvoir créer tous les sacs te ment la
même chose qu'eux
paraître la peau du requin blanc donc
j'ai remis les cicatrices on a fait des
yeux sur commande
on a roulé les dents de la mâchoire une
par une on a recréé la mâchoire du
dessous du dessus exactement celle qui
était la mâchoire aucun péché et donc il
a fallu à peu près quatre mois de boulot
donc j'ai été aidé par des collègues du
muséum une reconstitution à laquelle
s'ajoute le travail du peintre
ce dernier qui a suivi chaque étape a la
lourde tâche de trouver les couleurs et
la technique idéale pour parfaire
l'animal car s'allume a fini 2
blanchir on a masqué la toute la partie
blanche du rotin donc c'est le ventre en
fait tout le vent et en atteindre
j'épingle pistolet tout le tout le haut
quitte à un dégradé de gris de gris
jusqu'où gris foncé voilà et après il
nous restera donc 1 en lever toute la
partie cachée et il me restera toute la
partie de l'intérieur de la
la mâchoire atteindre les dans l'oeil et
toutes les cicatrices à faire les
finitions
le muséum d'histoire naturelle qu'on
déjà d'autres espèces comme le requin
bouledogue ou encore le requin tigre
mais l'emblématique requin blanc restait
le dernier trophée à ajouter à la
collection de notre taxidermiste pour
sony arrive
l'essentiel est avant tout la valeur
scientifique de cette prouesse technique
et artistique qui donne la valeur
scientifique à cet aspect siemens et qui
les fait d'après des mensurations qui
ont été prises par des chercheurs est
que ces mensurations était suffisamment
précises pour pouvoir faire je dirais un
requin en trois dimensions désormais
l'exposition requins prend toute sa
dimension grâce au travail remarquable
de salim un requin qui a pris ses
quartiers au muséum d'histoire naturelle
parmi ses autres congénères
une manière de regarder autrement les
requins et surtout de mieux comprendre
leur rapport à l'homme
c'est l'objectif de cette exposition